To solve for
this question, we only need to use one
tool in addition to the input data tool.
We simply connect the cross
tab tool to the input data.
The field that we're
grouping by is the city,
because the records will
be each of the cities.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
The new column headers
will be the school types,
so we choose type,
description, or type, desk.
The values in the columns
will be the enrollment, and
since we're looking to summarize
the enrollments by city and
type, we choose sum as the method.
When we run the workflow,
[SOUND] you can see that the school
types are listed across the top.
Regular, special ed, vocational,
tech, and other, and
the cities are the individual records.
With the sum of the enrollment
by city and by type.
If we filter the city field for
Laramie, we can see that
the number of enrollments for
Laramie that are vocational,
technical, and other, is 141.